[Music]
Halloweentown hi yeah okay this made so
many of these movies I'm surprised
there's not a Halloweentown surfs up or
how to cook with Halloweentown I mean
the possibilities are endless aren't
they the first one I couldn't really get
into aside from the makeup and the
second one I thought was legitimately
enjoyable even though they were bound to
just a few locations the third one falls
somewhere in between it pretty much just
jumps right in there as we see our
favorite family is toying with the idea
of maybe having kids from Halloweentown
go to school in the real world in
literally a flash the eldest daughter
who is actually the only daughter now
the youngest one seems to have just
disappeared
yeah Annesley no big loss he's in front
of the Halloween Town Council as willing
to put her idea to the test except well
her magic is on the line as well as the
magic of her entire family
oops so the kiss from Halloween town are
in disguise as Canadians yeah for an
exchange there that's really gonna be a
culture shock who are dressed up as
humans and are trying to be shown that
monsters and humans can get along but
unfortunately this evil organization
known as the Knights wants to keep these
two groups separate because they still
think humans are evil not tolerant and
are just gonna be awful for them and as
we discover they're willing to do
anything to keep them apart
I'm not gonna lie when I heard Halloween
Town High the first thing that came in
my head is oh cool a school in Halloween
Town seeing a bunch of ghouls and
monsters learn all sorts of creative
things it's kind of a letdown knowing
not only is it monsters going to the
real world school but it's monsters that
aren't even allowed to be monsters they
have to be in disguise looking like real
kids that's not much fun because of this
we don't really get that much in terms
of visuals and weird makeup and such
every once in a while there's something
cool like marshmallow spiders a bag that
walks and eats people and even the
Halloween kids are allowed to take off
their disguises once in a while and is
it me or did DreamWorks trolls totally
ripped us off thankfully though the
movie mostly makes up with this with
some okay writing and some genuinely
good performances I mean for a Disney
Channel movie I think we know we're not
gonna get anything spectacular here it's
funny seeing these actors who are just
so uncomfortable and awkward in the
first film suddenly seem very
Metroland very interested in what
they're saying as any good actor should
be any weird strange stuff they have to
say they really try their hardest to
make sound like this is just an everyday
thing and even the humans reacting to
their odd ways get a few laughs I
especially love this boy's reaction when
all the kids suddenly disappear into one
car why is none of this surprise B that
seems so believable to me the message is
made pretty clear as the villains once
they're revealed are trying to make a
whole group of people look bad based on
the actions of only a few and I'm not
gonna lie while I'm recording this and
watching the news this message does hold
a lot more relevance now than it
probably did back then it's kind of like
Zootopia what I thought was a little too
obvious and in-your-face sadly it turns
out is very very needed nowadays so I
guess even it's very simple message has
a lot more relevance the only thing that
was starting to get on my nerves a
little bit the performance of the
brother I don't know he's seeming a
little too OneNote to me just always
complaining always whining making fun of
everything don't get me wrong this is
very hard dialogue to make sound likable
and gets even stranger when he starts
dating one of the kids from Halloween
town until he sees what she really looks
like and suddenly he's disgusted it's
given a little bit of a spin we discover
she thinks he's disgusting too it's kind
of an interesting point of view for kids
the gross monster sees us as gross
monsters but in the end when it looks
like they're gonna see past it they
still say that they find each other
gross and they just decided to be
friends what a confusing message so yeah
where there are a lot of possibilities
that should have been taken advantage of
yes are there a lot more creative
elements I should have been here
absolutely but for what it is it kept my
interest I wanted to know what was gonna
happen I want to know how they're gay
get out of the predicament I enjoy the
monsters point of view as well as the
humans point of view and when they did
have those creative elements there were
a lot of fun I guess if you're curious
to see it just to say you've seen all
the Halloweentown movies it's not bad to
check out it's not gonna take anything
to new levels or anything but that's
totally ok nothing while worthy but
passable enough
you